do you think it's more correct to say
that pandemics may increase what climate
change or will increase with climate
change I feel comfortable saying will
increase with climate change hello I'm
Mary Jackson connecting with you from my
bedroom because of coronavirus this is
actually not a desk it's a $20 dresser
from Ikea I live in Los Angeles where
myself and other Angelenos are currently
sheltering in place and are working on
our screenplays at home rather than in
cafes in this video I'm going to be
explaining to you why pandemics may
increase in a warming world and
interview an expert about it I'm also
going to be telling some mediocre jokes
because the scariest and humor is my
coping mechanism see I know that your
grandparents and parents have been
talking to you just so much about
climate change but I thought it might be
refreshing for you to hear a young
person tackle the issue and explore how
it relates to cope at 19 hi I'm Alana
shake and I specialize in global health
in particular and strengthening global
health systems and what happens to those
systems when they face a severe shock I
think there's an interesting parallel
between our response to cope in nineteen
and our response to climate change I
think in a lot of ways the response to
Kovac 19 has been like climate change at
high speed first you get the experts
saying there's a massive problem coming
and governments and regular people say
don't be silly you're overreacting
we're not understanding the data or
choosing to ignore data cuz it's too
frightening and then you see it start
affecting people that are more distant
to you and then suddenly it's in your
backyard and everything's on fire in
case you missed it our world has warmed
by about one degrees Celsius or one
point eight degrees Fahrenheit from
pre-industrial levels since the
Industrial Revolution we've been burning
unprecedented amounts of fossil fuels
that release greenhouse gases like co2
into our atmosphere and trap heat from
the Sun causing our average global
temperature to rise so basically it's
likely to live in a house where none of
the windows open and we don't have a
decided it was a good idea to feed
everyone beans and burn all our
furniture now a 1 degree difference
doesn't seem like a lot but even half a
degree of warming can mean more deadly
heat waves increased water scarcity
entire island nations disappearing more
climate refugees trying to find homes
more floods droughts fires hurricanes
and diseases but like it's fine right
like let's just watch love is blind on
Netflix ok so let's get into the reasons
why pandemics may increase in a warming
world there may be an increase in
epidemics when there is a loss of
natural habitats due to climate change
which could cause humans and animals to
compete in closer proximity for
resources potentially spreading disease
this does sound like a bummer however I
would love to watch Gweneth Paltrow
wrestle a green juice from the jaws of a
mountain lion but that's an unlikely
outcome of climate change unfortunately
so one of the big challenges around
climate change and infectious disease
and zoonotic diseases in particular is
that extreme weather events and other
kinds of climate alterations also change
animals lives and animals habits on the
one hand we have people forcing
themselves into animal territory that
they've never been in before and on the
other hand you see animals being
disrupted by a confusing and
comprehensive the climate that start
blundering back into human environments
that they were previously avoiding and
those kinds of contacts between animals
and humans are what bring us zoonotic
diseases and what could well be part of
our next pandemic in the 2014 Ebola
epidemic climate change contributed to
the destruction of natural habitats for
animals like bats in West Africa forcing
the bats into closer proximity to humans
some hypothesize that this is how the
Ebola outbreak began in Guinea part of
the body's immune response is our
ability to kill off pathogens like
bacteria and viruses that cause disease
by becoming feverish and creating an
environment that is inhospitable for
pathogens to survive or that will make
you want to take off all your clothes as
would say however as the planet warms
pathogens evolved to become more
resistant to high temperatures for
example on a very hot summer day many
bacteria might die but those that do
survive are the stronger and more
adaptable bacteria and go on to
reproduce and pass on their heat
resistant genetics theoretically one day
as external temperatures continue to
rise our body's ability to kill off
bacteria with the natural heat of a
fever will become less effective just
like our ability to resist recreating
embarrassing tick-tock dances us
oftentimes disease is carried by animals
before it spreads to humans
however animals can have differing body
temperatures at which they can sustain
or fight off pathogens which are not
always equal to ours
for example it is believed that covin 19
may have spread to humans from bats bats
run a lot hotter than humans their body
temperature is commonly as hot as 105
degrees Fahrenheit so they can carry
pathogens that don't hurt them but that
can be hugely detrimental to humans
theoretically as the planet warms bats
and Joe exotic will still be protected
by their high body temperatures but we
will be far more vulnerable just kidding
about Joe exotic but I don't know about
McCarroll Basket as the world warms we
could see the spread of tropical
diseases like yellow and dengue fever in
places that they haven't historically
been like in North America to be clear
Kovan 19 is not a tropical disease or a
thing to mock by touching a bunch of
microphones a warming planet expands the
range that certain pathogens are
comfortable in like right now there's a
category of diseases called tropical
diseases and as more of the world falls
into a tropical zone those tropical
diseases will spread like there are
places in the world right now that you
don't get malaria and will start seeing
malaria there according to Maria de
iguazu at the Yale School of Public
Health global warming caused by humans
is likely to increase infection rates of
mosquito-borne diseases like malaria
dengue fever and West Nile virus this
would occur because a warmer planet
could create more mosquito friendly
habit
increasing the chances of humans getting
bit by mosquitoes carrying diseases and
unfortunately it won't be just the party
loving Spring Breakers who refused to
social distance who get bit global
drought could also lead to massive loss
of homes forced migration into urban
areas and increase vulnerability to
sickness due to overcrowding and lack of
resources in Syria a drought from 2006
to 2010 killed off 80% of the country's
livestock forcing over 1.5 million
Syrians into already crowded urban
centers and further stressing the
resources of a nation on the verge of
social uprising war and a humanitarian
crisis I believe the way we treat
climate refugees is going to leave the
disease outbreaks because when people
start moving around and then instead of
putting them in decent conditions we
pack them into things like refugee camps
with limited access to water and limited
access to decent toilet facilities
you're going to get disease outbreaks
then those are grannies friend another
fun thing for us to worry about is the
Arctic permafrost melting at increasing
rates due to our earth getting hotter
which mainly shhhh ancient viruses and
bacteria that haven't been seen in
centuries like the Dougy and missed that
chance frozen permafrost is the perfect
environment for microbes bacteria and
viruses to remain alive for thousands of
years maybe even up to a million years
because it is cold dark and lacks oxygen
like all the comment sections on YouTube
some viruses that may emerge could even
predate human life and be viral diseases
experienced by now extinct species like
Neanderthals but your friend whose DNA
test came back with one percent
Neanderthal will be fine or they won't I
don't know
in 2005 NASA scientists were able to
revive bacteria that had been frozen in
the Alaskan pond for 32 thousand years
the microbes they released had been
frozen since woolly mammoths were alive
and once thawed from the ice the
microbes began just swimming around
seemingly unaffected the same scientists
tried to revive vine but were
unsuccessful
Wow what a bevy of exciting new ways for
the human species to perish that we have
to look forward to
unfortunately the climate crisis isn't a
far-off reality like One Direction
getting back together but something that
we're already experiencing and will
sadly continue to experience in our
lifetimes like forgetting to cancel a
free trial of something when you only
really wanted to watch that one show in
case this video like really stressed you
out I'm sorry but there are things you
can do without a doubt governments and
corporations should be the ones that are
doing the big moves to address the
climate crisis but individuals can act
too
this crisis is so big and crazy like all
the drama and Joe exotics life that we
need everyone doing everything they can
on every level big and small I literally
can't stop talking about Joe exotic I'm
sorry during this time at home when a
lot of us are online shopping a small
thing you can do right away is to
consider consolidating your orders
together instead of ordering rolls of
toilet paper separately order them
together and opt for slower shipping
times to help cut down on emissions I
mean maybe you really need a vagina
candle in two days Who am I to tell you
you don't but think about it and you
know next time you're on the toilet look
and see if your favorite brand has a
sustainability plan and if it's a BS
greenwashing one consider supporting a
sustainable brand instead yes there's
more you can do
but I'm pleading with you to start
somewhere anywhere to help save this
blue marble we call home
well the earth will be fine actually
it's us who won't be
[Music]